On the 1st of May 1960, a Soviet
S-75 Dvina surface-to-air missile
smashed into an American U-2 spy plane
somewhere over the region of Sverdlovsk.
Not wanting to lose face either in front of
the press or the Soviets, the US government
concocted a cover story, claiming the plane
was a NASA research craft that went down after
getting into difficulties. They really went to
town trying to make the deception as plausible
as possible - explaining that the pilot had
radioed in a problem with his oxygen supply
shortly before contact with the plane was lost.
They even went so far as to ground the US air
force's entire fleet of U-2s, ostensibly to
check the oxygen delivery systems for faults.
It was an excellent piece of deception delivered
convincingly... but there was one small problem.
Actually, there were *two* really fucking
massive problems. First, the plane's pilot,
Gary Powers, had not, as the Americans believed,
died in the crash. He'd ejected safely and was
in the custody of the Soviets. Second, the U-2
spy plane, which was covered in more high tech
reconnaissance gear than a billionaire stalker,
had survived the missile strike with relatively
minor damage, and the Soviets could see all
too clearly that this was no research craft.
Seeing an opportunity to score a point against
their Cold War rivals, the Soviets wasted no
time parading both the pilot and large chunks
of the spy plane in front of the world's press.
To make matters even worse, the two
superpowers had been due to meet for
peace talks at a Paris summit just
two weeks after the plane was shot
down. With the Americans made to look like
mugs for planting such a public lie and the
Soviets furious that the Americans were
spying on them right before peace talks,
the summit was cancelled and the Cold War
continued unabated for the next 30 years.
All in all, the whole thing was a bit
of a disaster for everyone involved.
But there was one rather nice knock-on effect
- the 1960 U-2 incident directly led to the
development of what many people believe
is the greatest aeroplane ever built.
That's a pretty bold claim, but if
you watch to the end of this video,
trust me - you're going to agree.
This is the story of the Lockheed SR-71
Blackbird: the invincible spy plane.
When the U-2 first flew in 1955, the
US government believed its lofty 70
thousand-foot cruising altitude put it
out of range of Soviet radar systems.
As Gary Powers proved in 1960, that
very much wasn't the case. In fact,
Soviet radar technology was far more advanced than
the Americans had ever imagined, and that was a
serious problem. The Lockheed U-2 was relatively
slow with a large radar cross-section - if the
Soviet's could successfully track it, it was
nothing more than a very expensive flying duck.
The CIA invested serious cash trying
to make the U-2 less visible to radar,
but when those efforts failed it became
clear they were going to need a new
plane entirely - one that would truly be
invulnerable to Soviet air defence systems.
Of course, building an invincible aeroplane was
impossible... but it just so happens that the
Americans had an aeronautical engineer who'd built
a career out of making the impossible possible.
His name was Kelly Johnson, and to give you an
idea of the length and importance of his career,
I can tell you that he designed the
United's States first jet fighter,
the first military aircraft
to fly faster than 400 mph,
the first Mach 2 capable fighter, and
the first aircraft ever to exceed Mach 3.
Put simply, he is one of the most important
figures in the entire history of aviation.
At the time, he was head of Lockheed's Advanced
Development Projects, a department better known by
its nickname, the Skunk Works. Johnson's team was
relatively small, but comprised some of the finest
aerospace engineering minds not just in the US,
but the entire world. Together, Johnson and his
merry band of geniuses came up with a plane that
can only be described as a miracle of engineering.
The first iteration of that aircraft was known
as the A-12, and it was like nothing that had
ever been built before. It was developed under
a cloak of absolute secrecy, and first took to
the skies in the early 1960s when it was
tested at some place called Groom Lake,
though you may know it by another name: Area-51.
It was this plane - and others like it - that
helped build Area-51's reputation as the home
of secret alien technology, and it isn't hard
to imagine why: the A-12 wouldn't have looked
out of place in a Ridley Scott space epic.
By the way, if the name 'A-12' sounds familiar,
you might be thinking of one of Elon
Musk's children, who's called...
erm... uhh... yeah, no idea. The A-12 part of
the poor kid's... designation is a tribute to
Musk's favourite plane, the SR-71, which
is ultimately what the A-12 became.
To begin with there were 3 different variants -
the regular A-12 was a straight-up reconnaissance
plane, but there was also an interceptor -
the YF-12 - that was equipped with air-to-air
missiles and the particularly badass M-21,
which came with a detachable unmanned drone.
But none of those planes ever really, well,
took off, because waiting in the wings was
the A-12's successor, the SR-71, nicknamed
Blackbird for its striking paint job. Although,
little-known fact time - the paint was
actually an extremely dark shade of blue.
Capable of cruising 16 miles above the surface of
the earth at more than 3 times the speed of sound,
the SR-71 was the perfect spy plane - it was one
of the first built with a 'stealth' design that
dramatically reduced its radar signature,
and it flew so high and so fast that ground
fire couldn't touch it. By the time Soviet radar
systems locked on and SAM installations fired,
it was simply too late - the SR-71 was long
gone. During three decades of active service,
an estimated 4000 surface-to-air missiles were
fired at the SR-71. Not a single one hit its mark.
The Blackbird was such a revolutionary aircraft
that almost the entire thing had to be built
from scratch using new technology. Air
temperatures at cruising altitude were
in the region of -85 degrees celsius, but
the SR-71 flew so fast that friction with
the thin atmosphere generated temperatures of
beyond 300 degrees celsius across its frame.
When a Blackbird landed after a flight
at Mach 3, its hull was so hot you could
cook your dinner on it (although I'm
pretty sure that was frowned upon).
Regular aviation aluminium would begin to soften
if exposed to such extreme heat, so the SR-71 was
built almost entirely from a titanium alloy. That
was something that had never been done before, and
a whole new set of fabrication tools and methods
had to be invented before they could even start.
The incredible heat generated when the plane was
cruising at almost 3.5 times the speed of sound
caused other problems, too - the airframe
expanded by almost a foot as it warmed,
so all the plane's panels had to be fitted with
plenty of play. That extra wiggle room meant the
SR-71 steadily leaked fuel while on the ground,
because the fuel tanks didn't seal properly.
Incidentally, there happened to be a bit of
a shortage of titanium in the US at the time,
which was particularly unfortunate
because the vast majority of the
global supply came from the Soviet Union.
Buying direct clearly wasn't an option,
so the CIA had to establish a number of dummy
corporations to get Skunk Works what they needed.
The first SR-71s went into service
in 1966 about 7 months before the
England football team won the World
Cup (Which is completely irrelevant,
but it's always nice to mention
it). In total, just 32 were made.
These planes flew so high that SR-71 pilots
had to wear special pressure suits to prevent
their blood from boiling in their veins if the
cockpit's integrity happened to be breached,
and that incredible altitude meant the SR-71
could go where it pleased, though so far as we
know none were ever actually flown over the Soviet
Union - by this point in the Cold War, tensions
were simply too high to risk it. And besides,
the Blackbird could do a surprisingly good job
at gathering reconnaissance even from outside
of Soviet airspace. The planes were equipped
with side-facing cameras that could scan 100,000
square miles of enemy territory in a single hour.
For almost 30 years the SR-71 ruled the
skies, an untouchable phantom that would
occasionally coalesce on enemy radars
before disappearing into the ether.
We'll likely never know exactly
which missions were flown and where,
but it's thought that SR-71s were used all over
the world and in almost every major war zone.
But by the 1990s, the use-case for this
most impressive machine was beginning to
look a little shaky. For all its technological
brilliance, the SR-71 had one fatal flaw - it
lacked a live data feed, meaning any intelligence
it gathered couldn't be analysed until the craft
was back at base. The existing planes could
always have been upgraded, but emerging
technologies like spy satellites and unmanned
drones could do the same job more efficiently.
In the end, a combination of these new
technologies, politics, and the phenomenal running
costs of the SR-71 saw it retired, though plenty
of senior figures in the air force considered
the move to be a grave mistake. After all, spy
satellites could be slow to get into position,
and unmanned drone technology was still
in its infancy. But after briefly being
brought out of retirement in 1999, the SR-71
was mothballed for good shortly afterwards.
The Blackbird is a relic from another era - a spy
plane built almost 60 years ago that's long since
been replaced by newer, more advanced models...
replaced, but never surpassed. To this day,
the SR-71 remains the fastest air-breathing
aeroplane ever built, and it still holds numerous
point-to-point records, including the fastest
flight from New York to London - in 1974 it made
the journey in 1 hour 54 minutes, a full *hour*
faster than supersonic speed demon Concorde.
There’s something almost mythical about this
aeroplane. Those who built it talked about it
in hushed tones, and the pilots who flew it
were simply in awe - in the words of US Air
force Colonel Jim Watkins: At 85,000 feet and
Mach 3, it was almost a religious experience.
If you want to see an SR-71 for yourself today,
your only chance is to visit one of a select few
museums around the world that were lucky enough
to get one. But here's the good news - a successor
is in the works. Commonly referred to as ‘Son of
Blackbird,’ the SR-72 could fly as early as 2025.
As for whether it will live up to the legacy
of its progenitor, only time will tell.
Thanks for watching.